tell me about the queen her burial her
internment and what is happening with
that it was very poignant seeing the
bagpiper walk off
well the queen had said actually that
the lone piper was the most moving
moment for her of philip's
ceremony and it is the most haunting
sound and sight and very very very
emotive but i think that moment where
the queen's coffin was lowered down into
the royal vault was
very very powerful very emotional and
the king found that very very difficult
to watch but actually what viewers may
not realize is that the queen had it all
worked out because in that same royal
vault currently lying is the duke of
edinburgh's coffin and they will both be
interred together at this private
ceremony which won't be televised which
will only be for immediate family and it
was her wish that he waited for her in
the royal vault she said don't open up
my father's vault which is where they
will all end up together
because she knew she wouldn't be long
after and she wanted that final journey
to be made with philip by her side so
she really felt that her time was coming
after he passed
i think she ultimately died of a broken
heart really she was never the same
after philip when they'd been together
for 74 years
he was she said her strength and stay
he supported her in everything she did
in life i mean i think it's her to say
that she wouldn't be the queen that she
was without the support of philip and i
think something in her died when he went
and she held on for as long as she could
she she did her constitutional role she
saw in her new prime minister
she made sure she
tidied everything up and i think in the
end she just wanted to be back with him
and i think that's why we saw that
double rainbow over buckingham palace
and windsor castle
[Music]
you